[Música]
en el barrio de sal típica de la ciudad
ucraniana dejar que decenas de
ciudadanos viven en situaciones de
precariedad en medio de los permanentes
bombardeos nuestras unidades especiales
visitaron esta peligrosa zona el ex
presidente de brasil luiz inácio lula da
silva vuelve al ruedo y lanzó su
candidatura para las elecciones
presidenciales de octubre en un acto
multitudinario el líder pidió a los
brasileños que se unan a él para
defender la democracia
y costa rica se prepara para la toma de
posesión del presidente electo rodrigo
chávez este domingo el político tomará
las riendas de un país que pese a ser
uno de los más desarrollados de la
región ha registrado un deterioro
económico
hola bienvenidos a las noticias de
france 24 en español gracias por
acompañarnos y santiago ahorita y
comenzamos con información sobre la
guerra en ucrania y es que en el barrio
de sal tips que hablamos de uno de los
más devastados de la ciudad de jarquín
decenas de ciudadanos viven en
situaciones precarias mientras los
bombardeos rusos y ucranianos no se
detienen eren es sabio y leticia álvarez
enviadas especiales de france 24
estuvieron en esta peligrosa zona para
conocer de cerca la situación que vive
en sus habitantes
el calcinado mercado de bar abajo va una
iglesia ortodoxa rusa el hospital de al
lado incluso un centro juvenil de
deportes y apartamentos todo esto ha
sido alcanzado por las bombas vamos a
entrar en santista en este barrio vivían
antes medio millones de personas a la
mayoría
y los que quedan sobreviven como pueden
cerca de salt iscar este barrio el
dormitorio al noroeste de jarquín
disparan el ejército ruso y ucraniano es
difícil encontrar a personas paseando
por la calle porque es peligroso estar
aquí están a poca distancia de los
misiles línea y anatoli son de los pocos
que aceptan hablar
y
es increíble lo que le están haciendo al
pueblo ucraniano
según nos han asediado la gente vive en
la pobreza creo que los saqueos
comenzarán pronto la gente tiene hambre
frío no tiene ropa
tratamos de batería de repente línea
sale corriendo situación exclusiones
saliendo
[Música]
lina está asustada
ha sido un gran susto la contraofensiva
ucraniana para parar a las tropas rusas
en este frente del norte retumba en este
barrio devastado donde ni siquiera llega
la ayuda humanitaria
y las consecuencias de la guerra se
sienten en américa latina en medio de
las clases mundiales de cereales que
trajo la invasión rusa los países
líderes en la producción de granos como
por ejemplo argentina se alegran por sus
buenas cosechas el informe es de laurel
en plena época de recolección de soya y
maíz argentinas buena con los
agrodólares con la guerra en ucrania a
los granos se volvieron más caros en el
mercado mundial lo que podría ser una
gran oportunidad para la nación
suramericana donde casi el 67 por ciento
del dinero que ingresa al país proviene
de las exportaciones agropecuarias pero
los precios de los cereales no son los
únicos que subieron las perspectivas son
son buenas los precios son buenos todo
el único problema es que se nos disparó
todo lo que es insumos ya que los
fertilizantes son todos importados bien
en la mayoría de rusia
los insumos se han ido por las nubes
algunas cosas se han triplicado
el tema del gasoil se calcula que
estamos trabajando con una sueldo sobre
precio frente a la fuerte subida de los
precios de los combustibles y de los
fertilizantes miles de manifestantes
salieron a las calles de la capital
buenos aires hace 15 días los tractores
furiosos marcharon para denunciar una
presión fiscal generalizada
es una rebaja impositiva difícil y
lamentablemente no podemos aprovechar
los precios internacional y todo lo que
tengo en producción para seguir
sosteniendo el país no tenemos
beneficios con lo que nos está robando
porque las retenciones en nuestra
ganancia y los beneficios de la gente
los manifestantes también mostraron su
temor ante la reciente propuesta de un
impuesto para redistribuir los
beneficios inesperados de la guerra
entraña un proyecto que no debería
afectar al final a los productores según
las últimas declaraciones de parte del
ministerio de agricultura
en otras noticias el ex presidente de
brasil luiz inácio lula da silva lanzó
su campaña para convertirse nuevamente
en presidente del país en un acto
multitudinario prometió reconstruir
brasil después de lo que caracterizó
como una desastrosa administración por
parte del mandatario de extrema derecha
ya ir bolsonaro
más de una década después de dejar el
cargo como el presidente más popular en
la historia de brasil luiz inácio lula
da silva anunció su campaña para las
elecciones presidenciales de octubre el
icono de izquierda fue encarcelado por
supuestos cargos de corrupción en 2018 y
posteriormente liberado en 2019 en marzo
de este año fue absuelto y pudo
postularse como candidato
necesitamos situar a brasil de nuevo
entre las mejores economías del mundo
necesitamos revertir el lento proceso de
desindustrialización del país y crear un
ambiente de estabilidad política
económica e institucional que anime a
los empresarios a invertir de nuevo en
brasil con la garantía de un retorno
seguro y justo para ellos para el país y
para el pueblo trabajador
cómo está el presidente yair bolsonaro
ganó las elecciones de 2018 en medio de
una ola de indignación contra lula y el
partido de los trabajadores
posteriormente la corte suprema- hay o
parcialidad por parte del juez principal
en el caso sergio moro lula ha estado
disfrutando de una vez baja en las
encuestas antes de la votación de
octubre
no tenemos tiempo a perder
no tenemos tiempo que perder en el odio
nunca haremos lo que hace nuestro
adversario que trata de ocultar su
incompetencia luchando todo el tiempo
con todos y mintiendo siete veces al día
la verdad libera y brasil necesita la
paz para progresar la verdad y libertad
y crisis de tu país para poder a pesar
de estar por delante en las encuestas la
victoria aún está lejos de ser segura
pulsión haro ha estado recuperando
terreno en las últimas semanas lula ha
hecho comentarios sobre temas como la
policía y el aborto que corren el riesgo
de alejar a algunos votantes también
critica a la clase media brasileña por
hacer alarde de su nivel de vida el ex
presidente de 76 años dejó el cargo en
2010 con altos índices de aprobación
luego de presidir un auge económico que
sacó de la pobreza a unos 30 millones de
brasileños
y costa rica se prepara para la toma de
posesión del presidente electo rodrigo
chávez este domingo el político liberal
en lo económico e ideológicamente
conservador en temas como por ejemplo el
aborto deberá tomar las riendas de un
país que pese a ser uno de los más
desarrollados de la región ha venido
registrando un deterioro en sus
indicadores económicos el informes de
alva santana
es una de las democracias más sólidas de
latinoamérica pero costa rica también
enfrenta crecientes retos de pobreza
desempleo y criminalidad entre otros que
tendrá que asumir el nuevo presidente de
la nación lomé comprometido y me
empeñaré en impulsar profundos y
positivos cambios en la forma de
gobernar costarrica
democráticamente y es que a pesar de que
costa rica está considerado como uno de
los países con mayor escolaridad calidad
y esperanza de vida de latinoamérica en
los últimos años se ha venido
registrando un deterioro en sus
indicadores económicos debido a un
escaso crecimiento económico agravado
por la pandemia de kobe 19 que debilitó
el turismo sectores clave en el país por
lo que la nación centroamericana ha
visto crecer hasta el 23 por ciento su
índice de pobreza que estaba en torno al
21 por ciento antes de la pandemia y
hasta cerca del 14 por ciento el
desempleo superior también a los niveles
pre pandemia
no hay trabajo no hay nada pero de ahora
en adelante llamo desde que luche por
este país porque somos costarricenses
tienen que luchar al igual que durante
el mandato de carlos alvarado se espera
que las políticas ambientales estén en
el centro del nuevo gobierno ya que el
país lleva la delantera regional en el
combate contra la crisis climática con
un ambicioso plan de alcanzar la
neutralidad climática para 2050 lo que
sí espero es que las cosas que hemos
logrado en estos años es el liderazgo
internacional en materia climática o esa
reivindicación de derechos humanos o la
estabilidad macroeconómica no se eche
para atrás
chávez también deberá combatir la
corrupción y el narcotráfico que ha ido
en aumento en el país debido a su
ubicación estratégica en la ruta del sur
al norte del continente una situación
con la que el nuevo presidente ha
prometido terminar
es todo por el momento regresamos en
breve con más noticias sigan entre más
24 y también por supuesto en france 24
punto com
[Música]